hi my name is sam kamkar i'm a security
researcher computer hacker and
co-founder of openpath security i've
been challenged today to explain
one simple concept in five levels of
increasing complexity
my topic hacking hacking to me is using
or manipulating a system
in a way that it wasn't intended or
really expected
and that could be a computer or it could
be a phone
or a drone or a satellite could really
be anything do you know what computer
hacking is
it's bad like um going into someone's
like personal account or account
changing some stuff or just stealing
some information
or your money yeah it's crazy they're
really a lot of bad or malicious hackers
out there
who are doing just that they're going
into people's accounts
and they're stealing money but there's
also another side of computer hacking
where there are people who are trying to
learn how those bad hackers are actually
breaking in
to the bank accounts did they like
return the money like give them their
money
or something like that what they're
trying to do is they're trying to even
prevent the bad hackers from getting in
in the first place
so they put like a protection account or
something yeah
exactly they're looking for ways that
they can create protection it's kind of
like
the lock on your front door that lock is
to essentially
prevent bad people from coming in or
people accidentally coming in when they
shouldn't
a hacker is essentially looking at a way
how can i get into this lock
but then there are the good ones who are
trying to unlock it so that they can
tell the company that made the lock hey
we can actually protect people by making
the lock a little harder
what would they do about the people in
the broken lock in many cases they'll
send them a new lock
so it's an upgraded a better version
sometimes that's new features but
sometimes that's bug fixes and ways to
protect you as well
but like they may get arrested because
they might get mistaken
that's a very good point you should
definitely make sure that you're obeying
the law they might work with the lock
company and say i'm trying to
improve your product and they're trying
to find these holes or problems
and then share that with the company
even though the good hacker is doing
exactly the same thing as the bad hacker
it's the same exact skill set and you're
using the same exact
techniques and information to try to
break that lock but
your goal is a good hacker is really to
help everyone like you and me to make
sure that our
stuff is protected so hopefully they
don't get in trouble because they're the
good guys
when did you start doing like the good
hacking i started doing
the good hacking when i turned nine
years old wow i started
going on the computer and playing video
games but i had some ideas of my own and
that's
where i started to learn how to hack i
wanted to play with my friends
on this video game and just change the
way that things look
but that would be kind of like bad
because maybe the creator did it for a
reason
that's entirely possible they may have
done it for a reason but
you may have come up with a really good
idea that do you think there are other
people who might like the idea that you
came up with
yeah when you have creative ideas like
that hacking can actually allow you to
change the way a system works and that
means you can change a game
and how the game is played and then you
can share that with your friends and
other people who like that game once i
started learning how to do it
i found that things that were harder for
me i could make easier did your parents
improve with it
i don't think my parents knew
but when my parents found out that i was
doing it for good i think they were
happy
do you do anything with computers or any
coding i like to play
coding games and i like to go on
code.org and
they have a variety of games for like
different ages so like i
really like to do that for example like
the game flappy bird
it's like puzzle pieces so they would
like tell you to connect something
and then you would play the game and
then you could see what you connected
interesting so it's like a graphical
interface where you can connect
different pieces together kind of like
wire them together
yeah oh that's pretty cool what do you
know about computer hacking i don't
really
know much about computer hacking
actually so on code.org one of the
things you've been doing is actually
building a game or that they have a game
and then you can actually rewire some of
the inputs and outputs of that is that
right
yeah okay with computer hacking it's
actually
the same thing uh really you have some
sort of system and you have a bunch of
inputs and you have some sort of output
and actually you as the designer
you're essentially designing games and
software
you're saying well i will only allow a
user
to really control these inputs can you
think of any inputs the computer might
have
spacebar yep there's also things like
your mouse and there's even things like
the microphone itself is actually an
input device it's
it's taking something from you which is
the sound and it's then transmitting
that and it's actually sending it to me
are there any other things that you can
talk to a computer you can give it
information camera that's absolutely
another
input that exists on your computer
that's how i try to think of things is
there's just a bunch of inputs
often if you're trying to break
something or hack something you're
really saying okay
how can i control these inputs in a way
that wasn't necessarily expected what
inputs would you normally use to hack
typically it's going to be something
like the keyboard right i'm just going
to be typing
keystrokes to be talking to some piece
of software or hardware
but other times it can be other things
like even the temperature of a computer
can actually affect how the computer
operates
and it might be advantageous to me to
cool down the computer
and actually slow down the movement of
electrons in something like
memory so that when a computer shuts off
it stores something that was in memory
like a password
and stores it for longer enough time
that i might be able to actually extract
it
through some other method how long does
it take to get in it just depends what
you're trying to do
in some cases it could literally be
seconds because you already know how the
system works
in other times it could be yours so what
have you learned about hacking
i think hacking is actually really
interesting there's different languages
to hack in
i've also learned that a lot of things
could be hacked that like
you don't necessarily think that could
be hacked
have you started studying cyber security
i started this year i
took my first course so haven't gone too
deep into it but
we got a basic idea of like basics of
information and network security we
learned about how
networks are set up like the different
type of topologies like star and mesh
and also how networks are designed with
different levels of security have you
heard of the breach of
target where they were reached many
years ago and their point of sale
systems were hacked
yes i heard about that so where people
are swiping credit cards those credit
card numbers were stolen
they hired a company to come in and
perform a penetration test to see
can the good guys essentially break in
again to prevent this sort of thing in
the future
and when this team came in they found
they actually were able to get pretty
much to the same point of sale system
and the way they did that was by
exploiting an internet connected
delhi meet scale once the company was
able to essentially get into the delhi
scale
because the daily scale was on the
internal network
then they were able to really escalate
privilege and find a vulnerability
within
another system essentially that just got
them into the network
and once you're in the network it's
often really easy to then escalate from
there
i've heard about similar attacks in
hospitals using
hospital equipment but i'm surprised
that something as simple as a meat scale
would have been used in such an attack
we discussed it in class as
how hackers look at some of the weakest
links in these large networks and use
that
those to tap into networks yeah that's a
another interesting concept is really
just different layers that we have
for protection because often when you're
talking about something like a corporate
network
or even your home network you typically
have sort of one level of the defense
right
if someone can break that or can get in
through some other system
that is connected or exposes some other
protocol like bluetooth right you can
connect to a bluetooth device
without being on the wireless network
without being on the lan
that potentially gives you another place
that you can pivot
on and then access other devices because
if something has both bluetooth
and also wi-fi well if you can get in
through bluetooth then you can then
access the wi-fi
and get to other devices on the network
are you familiar with buffer overflows
no i'm not familiar with that if we were
to write a program that
asked for your name and you you typed in
your name
but before you could type in your name
in a low level language like series c
plus plus
you'd have to allocate some memory so
you might allocate a buffer of
100 bytes because whose name is going to
be longer than 100 bytes
or 100 characters but what happens if
you were to
not really check that they limited to
100 bytes
do you know what happens if they
essentially start typing over that 100
bytes
in that case there it would be an error
for accessing
invalid memory absolutely you descent
essentially cause like a
segmentation fault yeah but what's
really cool about that is
when you're going into memory you're
starting to cross over that boundary of
that 100 byte allocation and now you're
starting to write over
additional memory that other memory is
really important stuff so you have your
like your name the 100 bytes there
and then right next to your name is the
return address and that's the address
that
the code is going to execute is going to
return to after that function is done
and it's going to jump to that address
but after you type your 100 bytes
the next few bytes that you type you're
actually going to overwrite that return
address
so that return address could essentially
be another address
in memory so what you end up doing is
you type a name and it's not really a
name it's really just code and that code
you keep typing
until you get to the return address and
you start typing an
address which is really the beginning of
your name and
your computer your your processor is
actually going to read that address
and it will jump back to the beginning
and then execute
that payload so that was sort of the
very first thing that i think was super
exciting to me when i
started learning about really reverse
engineering so how does
the buffer overloading
relate to what you are doing in terms of
network security or
designing software for penetrating
testing
ever since buffer overflow started many
years ago there have been a lot of
protection mechanisms built to
make it difficult to exploit more and
more we're actually using
smaller and smaller computers with small
amounts of compute power if you take a
car
you have hundreds of microcontrollers
that are all
running there so they don't really have
a sophisticated operating system that
can try to prevent
attacks like buffer overflows so how do
we keep these low-cost computers
in here while adding layers of
protection to prevent malice
and these types of attacks sometimes it
actually is how can we write software or
how can we build a system that prevents
these types of attacks from entering but
oftentimes it's really looking for
how can we find new attacks that we
haven't even necessarily thought of
what got you interested in computer
science and information security i got
interested in cyber security because i'm
really into global affairs global
politics
and you often hear in the news about the
rising power of china the rising power
of
um iran i enjoy how interdisciplinary
computer science is like nowadays
there's so much going
on in the world of computers and that's
what fascinated me
you brought up china and iran and
something that's interesting about
those areas is really censorship right
they have essentially censored internet
in the us we have a really interesting
internal struggle here where we actually
have uh government agencies like
the state department that are funding
software to evade censorship like
tor and other mechanisms while then we
also have
an internal struggle where we have other
organizations like the nsa who are
specifically looking to break that exact
same system
that the us government is also funding
there are a lot of like ethical
questions about whether we should be
intervening in other countries but
it's pretty interesting that two
different agencies at the government are
actually
working on contrasting technology i can
actually understand that because
if we are creating a technology that
we're going to deploy somewhere else we
should
know its limitations we should know how
to control it it's good for us to
understand like how these systems can
really break down
although the i think one thing that i
see is that some of let's say the
organizations that are looking to break
this
are not necessarily going to share once
they actually learn that information
they might actually
sort of hold that in their back pocket
and use it when it's advantageous to
them
what kind of projects are you working on
this is the end of my first year i'm a
phd student at nyu
tandon school of engineering i'm
studying security systems and operating
systems
so security for operating systems i've
been mostly working on a project
that limits executables exposure to bugs
in the kernel it's run by professor
justin kapos there
he found that the majority of bugs that
occur in
the linux kernel happen when you're
doing things that
people don't do that often that programs
don't do that often
so designing like a runtime environment
that lets you
limit what a certain program has
access to but also the things that it
does have access to is also limited to
those popular paths in the kernel so it
can't access
areas that aren't under more scrutiny so
essentially it's a really
potentially a stripped down operating
system or i guess
i guess it's a virtual machine basically
we're creating a user space
operating system have you done any work
in side channel analysis like a little
bit i've
like read the row hammer paper i found
it really interesting but it's nothing
that i've actually worked with
so the side channel analysis is really
looking
not at vulnerability within a system but
really
unintended consequences of what the
system is built on a very simple example
of maybe site
of a side channel is putting your ear to
the ground
to hear if their horse is coming towards
you and the same thing applies to
technology
so you can have something like a cpu
it's executing instructions
certain instructions use a little bit
more power and power is reserved in
these capacitors which are like tiny
batteries next to your cpu
and as they're pulling power there's
something in physics called the
electro-restrictive effect
where the capacitor will move in a very
very tiny amount
and then although we can't hear it the
microphone on a mobile device can't
actually listen to that
if you then listen to that and you say
oh i see a pattern here and you can go
all the way down and then extract
reveal the full password the full key
even though it could be argued that
the algorithm itself there's no problem
with it so all memory devices are just
it's just a bunch of gates and they'll
they're in rows
they basically all hold different pieces
of memory that's all the gates are
either they're turned on or they're
turned off so what rowhammer found was
to test a bunch of different memory
devices and found that by doing a
certain order of
storing things and then pulling that
information back
in a certain way in one place would
actually
flip gates in a different place so
that you could actually do a bunch of
things to a piece of memory that had
nothing to do with
something that may be critical in a
different place and actually change its
contents
and that obviously exposes all sorts of
security issues
um because that's that's very hard to
predict yeah i suppose the physical
adjacency right of the underlying
transistors and capacitors that are
holding that
that storage that's that's crazy i think
the first time i heard of
an interesting attack like that was
learning about uh the cold boot attack
um being able to you know someone
enters their password on their computer
and that decrypts their hard drive and
then they
they walk away being able to extract
that password is really difficult
if i can pull that memory chip out and
extract that memory put it in my own
device except the problem is memory is
volatile so it'll
erase as soon as i pull it out you can
take something like that canned air
turn it upside down cool that computer
make it real nice and cool
then you have a minute or two to pull
out the memory put it in your own device
extract the memory and then you're good
such a simple method
to really extract something kind of
critical like row hammer
it's such a low level vulnerability and
it's you know you could argue that it's
not necessarily a vulnerability in the
in the architecture itself but rather
exploitation of physics at that point
i've spent a decent amount of time with
this stuff in
my mind a lot of that is a nightmare
over the last year while i was doing
some other stuff i actually
designed some microcontroller boards for
a company that was doing stuff with
like a smart watering project the
problems with like updating
is just like that's scares me the most
like people don't update
their own stuff let alone these like
devices i keep forgetting to update my
fridge
i find myself like trying to shy away
from owning
like smart things that's pretty
challenging if you want to use wireless
right if you want to use a wireless
router yeah i mean there's obviously
essentials
no matter what you can't really avoid
any of this the risk
right now just during uh this quarantine
is actually
massive now now that we think about it
because you might have these legacy
systems you know they were built
20 30 years ago and it's too costly to
upgrade
but now you can't actually have a lot of
people in a central location in a single
location
so potentially they actually do have to
now add some sort of remote capabilities
to these systems that were never meant
to be on the internet have you ever had
any ethical concerns with
the stuff you're interested in or the
work you do oh yeah for sure when people
find
vulnerabilities i think it's their duty
to release those to the public
especially
now that we're seeing more and more
companies who are trying to make it
illegal
for you to inspect the vehicle that
you've purchased
right something that you actually own
yeah i think that's nuts i'm
i'm firmly against that for sure what if
it were illegal uh would you
would you then do it fortunately it's
not today right it hasn't been you know
that
despite their attempts none of that has
been passed um
but if you had a vehicle and you wanted
to inspect it but all of a sudden it
passed i mean
i don't know uh probably yeah
[Laughter]
no i don't think that's hurting anyone
but the laws don't
always equate to hurting anyone i
ethically think
similar to you and that you know what is
moral to me is as long as i'm not
intentionally hurting others
right yeah i think we see every day that
ethics and the laws aren't
necessarily the same thing all the time
hey colin uh we already know each other
but why don't you introduce yourself for
the people watching
hi i'm colin o'flynn i live in halifax
nova scotia canada
i do hardware hacking both in academia
at dalhousie university
in an industry of my startup new ae
technology what have you been up to and
yeah what are you working on lately i've
been doing um you know always a little
bit of side channel analysis so what i
really do you know is all hardware layer
so i've been looking
uh you know on some various devices
lately uh how susceptible they are to
fault
attacks uh what that sort of means in
real life
you know not just purely the the
research side but also
how much should you care about it uh
maybe a mutual acquaintance of ours uh
jasper
gave an example of fault injection and i
like to use that as
what is like when i'm trying to explain
fall injection he shows
a pinball machine and the pinball
machine obviously the two inputs are the
plun the two plungers when you're
playing a pinball machine
but fault injection you can tilt the
entire
pinball machine right you're just
introducing some external variable
that's outside of the
traditional inputs that you're used to
and you've now controlled the
environment in an
advantageous way to the the user or the
player can you give an example of
some type of fault injection that you're
doing or working on one of them
was looking at like a little hardware
bitcoin wallet
and you could use fault injection to
actually recover secrets from it
um and a lot of devices i mean the whole
idea is pretty cool right because
you tell the device hey i want to
authenticate um
and it's supposed to run some really
crazy math that authenticates it but
instead of
doing that crazy math and attacking the
math you just attack the check at the
end
we're also scratching the surface of
like what is possible it's not
necessarily just
the system itself and not necessarily
that algorithm itself like like
you said you don't necessarily need to
attack the math in some cases you can
just attack that
check and i think something that's been
pretty cool is looking at higher energy
particles it's going to be maybe hard to
entirely confirm but i think it'd be
really really cool to actually
see like i want to see one of these
faults because i haven't
seen it myself and also how do you know
that you've seen it
i've started playing with like a setting
up a cloud chamber a cloud chamber lets
you actually view
high energy particles going through sort
of like in a in a small jar
with some evaporated alcohol and i
thought it'd be really cool
if we put some memory chip in there like
a basic memory chip
and we just fill it with some data but
then you put a camera on that area
and you just watch assuming that there
is a high
particle high energy particle that
actually hits that memory that should
potentially potentially flip
the energy state of that bit the outside
microcontroller should be able to read
that
and actually say oh wait the data
changed even though i'm not changing
data i'm only reading data
and we should be able to visibly or
optically see it what i'm wondering is
could that be a next area of research
because i don't think anyone's actually
looking at intentionally injecting high
energy particles
to take over a computer when really
that's what
you know that's another technique for
fault injection technically speaking
this was actually tied into something
recently i was looking at
um which was you know flipping flash and
eprom
memory you mean flipping bits within
flash yeah exactly right so flipping
it in this sort of flash memory and so
someone's done it with x-rays there's
actually
uh i forget who now there's a paper at
least one and it's just like little
plate right they make with like a hole
in it to
concentrate the x-ray source and it
works like
so yeah it's it's super interesting like
one bit in memory means a lot especially
the flash memory side
yeah visualizing it would be cool though
i've never seen um
uh maybe call it a verifiable
visualization of it right we
we know it's true you know you can get
skin cancer by going outside and having
uh too many high and high energy
particles hit you um
but we've never seen it and we know it
can happen to a computer chip but i've
never seen like
both yeah so actually so it's funny you
mentioned like making it uh
more obvious for
state i mean staying on fault injection
right now this is lately what i've been
up to a lot of
uh making a little kind of you know like
electronics kits of old right and you
can assemble it all yourself and see how
it works
um so making something like that for
fault injection so all kind of older
logic
and stuff like that so um i mean it's
sort of based on like you had presented
the the little mux chip
you know voltage glitcher that sort of
idea uh using
just discrete logic to generate the um
the actual glitch itself so but you know
it's part of i think
this stuff right it's like people don't
know about it sometimes like even
engineers designing systems
it's it's new to a lot of people the
thing is even if you know about that
then there's so many others that someone
won't necessarily know about because
there's so many i guess
potential areas for for a fall to occur
where do you think security is going or
new research is going are
any new areas you think are coming out
are going to be more interesting
you know pretty soon fault injection i
think has become pretty interesting like
there's been a lot of people
poking at that and i think a lot more
products of interest um side channels
still
might have a bit of a comeback basically
what i kind of see is a lot of
the really cool stuff has been in
academia because
product security hasn't capped up right
for the longest time doing these attacks
on hardware was pretty
straightforward you didn't need these
crazy attacks
it looks like a lot of devices are
coming out now that actually have
real claims to security right more than
just
a data sheet mentioned there's actually
something behind it
for me i think the things that have been
recent and super interesting are
typically down to
like physics levels effects that maybe
we haven't seen before
i think my mind was blown with the there
was the light commands research
and they were able to modulate sound
although it's purely over light
using a laser they would hit the mems
microphone and it was picking that up
and was able to then interpret it and
essentially
get take control over light i'm curious
of the back story to how they found that
uh because if you told me that right
said you said like hey colin you should
test this out i probably
would be like i probably won't even work
right which is like a lot of side
channels when i first heard about it
uh you know working doing firmware stuff
it was like ah that sounds like it's not
gonna work like that sounds impossible
you know the whole area of the hardware
backing it feels kind of like
cheating because you know as you said
someone designing the system needs to
know about like so many different ways
right so
there's so many ways to break the system
and if you're designing them you need to
know like all of them but when you're
attacking it you really need to know one
right so i can know nothing about
like how does ecc like actually work you
know i have some vague hand waving i can
tell you about
uh but if you gave me a pen until you
okay write it down specifically the
equations and what they mean and how the
point mall works and stuff
right no idea the designers are like the
other side
it's almost like the i want to say lazy
side of it
it's the easier side i i would say my
side is the easier side right i'm on the
offensive side i want to break into
things
someone on the defense side might they
might have a you know a system was
developed and they now need to patch a
hundred holes
uh they patch 99 of them i only need to
find that one yeah there's no downsides
is what you're saying yeah only when you
get caught i hope you learned something
about hacking
maybe next time a system behaves in a
way that you weren't expecting you might
just be curious enough to
try to understand why thanks for
[Music]
watching